chacun est responsable là où il est moi
je suis membre de l'est républicain qui
a été créé il ya 15 ans j'y suis je me
suis battu pendant toutes ces années
pour qu'il y ait un bon accueil des
centristes comme moi des personnes
modéré très heureux et nous plaît nous
avons à dire voilà nous créons agir
parce que enfin moi j'ai pris la mesure
bureau politique après bureau politique
de la difficulté à s'exprimer à
travailler aussi à rezai qui je crois
qu'elle trouve sa source en fait dans
l'entre-deux tours des présidentielles
quand on n'est pas arrivé collectivement
à dire il faut voter pour emmanuel
macron vous aider marine le pen en face
le front national et qu'on a rédigé un
texte très compliqué bref on avait
renoncé à cette ligne rouge vis-à-vis du
front national et à partir de là on n'a
pas su parler de cette incroyable
défaite à il ya un an exactement
on devait gagner la présidentielle la
seule question c'est est qui serait
notre champion est aussi aujourd'hui est
ce que c'est la droite l'euro wauquiez
qui ne vous satisfait pas tel que
aujourd'hui elle se dessine moi je
dénonce j'annonce pas je sais c'est très
simple vous partez autre que vous fonder
un nouveau parti c'est parce que vous ne
vous reconnaissez plus dans une certaine
droite les républicains là celle de la
ligne non convoqué c'est tout à fait
cela je constate qu'il y a un
déplacement vers des idées très
conservatrice vers des thèses très
excluante je ne trouve pas de discours
européen et je ne trouve pas beaucoup de
capacité à construire à avancer à
s'ouvrir et j'ai beaucoup de mal à faire
comme un certain nombre de républicains
c'est à dire à attaquer des mesures qui
étaient dans notre propre projet